[Music]
here we see cells flowing through the
bloodstream but let's focus on this
rolling macrophage that sticks to the
endothelial cells that line the blood
vessels by adhering to proteins it's
almost like molecular velcro the surface
of the cell is remarkably dynamic with
membrane proteins that form connections
with other cells and respond to external
signals if we flip across the membrane
and look on the inside of the cell
we'll see this remarkable internal
architecture made up of the cytoskeleton
it's very similar to the structural
elements that's holding up the ceiling
over your head but unlike those
structural elements these are very
dynamic they assemble and in this case
we're looking at an actin filament for
several actin filaments assembling but
they can also disassemble when other
proteins sever those structural elements
here we're looking at a microtubule
which is much more complex but it too
assembles and disassembles in some truly
remarkable ways these structural
elements also serve as highways that
motor proteins use to drag for example
vesicles these vesicles are full of
proteins and other macromolecules that
are distributed throughout the cytoplasm
of the cell
[Music]
messenger RNAs are transported out of
the nucleus and serve as templates for
protein translation so ribosomes
assemble on these messenger rnas and as
those proteins are made some of them are
free to float in the cytoplasm while
others bind to other proteins that help
target them to organelles such as this
mitochondrion that you're seeing right
now still other proteins are translated
directly into other organelles like the
endoplasmic reticulum the endoplasmic
reticulum releases vesicles once again
containing proteins and other
macromolecules so here we see the Golgi
apparatus
that's receiving vesicles and also
releasing vesicles some of which fuse
with the plasma membrane and dump their
cargo into the external environment and
also release transmembrane proteins into
the plasma membrane these proteins can
change their shape dramatically in
response to external signals these
changes in shape allow them to bind to
other proteins which in the case of this
macrophage causes it to stop rolling
dramatically change shape and squeeze in
between two neighboring and Abilio cells
to go and fight infection in the tissue
you
you
[Music]